[Musique]
le gouvernement du Québec peut choisir
et à notre sens doit choisir de geler
les tarifs de l'État c'est pas le temps
d'augmenter le fardeau nous construisait
c'est le temps des aides et le gel des
tarifs tels qu'on vous le propose c'est
une façon concrète de le faire les
députés québécois retourneront au Salon
bleu cette semaine presque deux mois
après le scrutin François Legault a déjà
indiqué qu'il voulait profiter de la
courte séance pour déposer un mini
budget et permettre les remises de 400 à
600 dollars annoncé en campagne pour
aider certains contribuables à lutter
contre l'inflation une importante
préoccupation pour la carte que compte
bien partager Québec solidaire qui a
recadré son message cette semaine pour
faire de la lutte à l'inflation sa
priorité à court terme j'en discute avec
le cours de parole de QS Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois que je rejoins dans nos studios
de Québec monsieur Nadaud Dubois bon
dimanche merci d'être avec nous bonjour
ça me fait plaisir vous avez dit
mercredi dernier que la crise du coût de
la vie serait dorénavant votre priorité
pourquoi c'est pas une priorité durant
la campagne ça a été aussi une priorité
durant la campagne électorale on se fait
notamment engagé à des taxer tous les
biens essentiels au Québec si Québec
cellulaire formait le gouvernement là on
aura une très courte session
parlementaire en seulement deux semaines
donc on s'est choisi en focus mercredi
un cheval de bataille principale celui
du coût de la vie pourquoi mais parce
que c'est la priorité des gens en ce
moment moi je suis dans ma
circonscription à Montréal depuis depuis
les dernières semaines et chaque jour on
reçoit des appels des courriels les gens
nous en parle tout coûte de plus en plus
cher donc c'était un choix évident pour
nous que de faire de la question du coût
de la vie la priorité numéro 1 pour
cette courte session parlementaire
l'élément principal que vous avez mis de
l'avant c'est un gel des tarifs pour un
an la carte propose les limiter à 3% la
carte propose aussi d'envoyer un chèque
directement au contribuables québécois à
un autre chèque devrait-on dire pourquoi
pourquoi ça c'est pas une proposition
c'est pas une solution qui peut combler
justement les besoins des gens qui font
face à l'inflation envoyer des chèques à
presque tout le monde je vous ai il y a
personne qui crache ou qui déchire un
chèque quand il rentre par la poste mais
c'est une aide qui est très large qui
est possible et auprès des familles qui
en ont le plus besoin et surtout c'est
de l'argent qui va être très vite
dépensé on réglera pas on n'aidera pas
les familles à traverser cette crise de
l'inflation seulement avec une mesure ni
un chèque ni un plafonnement de la
hausse des tarifs à 3% ce qu'on lui
demande de faire c'est gelé tous les
tarifs du gouvernement pendant un an
vous avez dit la semaine dernière bon
c'est une courte session vous l'avez
mentionné tout à l'heure en début
d'entrevue vous avez dit aussi qu'il y
aurait d'autres propositions dans cette
veine là quel genre de proposition
je vais pas brûler tout mes punch
aujourd'hui
est-ce que avec le coût de la vie
actuelle le salaire minimum permet de
vivre dans la dignité la réponse de
quiconque c'est faire des mathématiques
c'est non le gouvernement est en train
de réfléchir actuellement à l'approche
du salaire minimum vous pouvez compter
sur Québec solidaire pour l'interpeller
dans les prochaines semaines pour lui
demander de procéder à une hausse
significative du salaire minimum en ce
moment au Québec il y a des gens qui
travaillent à temps plein et qui vont
quand même dans les banques alimentaires
pour remplir leur panier d'épicerie ça
c'est une rupture de notre contrat
social ça ne devrait pas fonctionner
comme ça dans notre société c'est une
des batailles qu'on va mener dans les
deux prochaines semaines sur le front du
coup de la vie la crise du coût de la
vie de la crise climatique à la crise du
coût de la vie vous êtes quoi à que vous
êtes en train de recadrer votre message
je leur dis que la crise climatique
c'est une bataille en moyen long terme
donc les gens pourront toujours compter
sur Québec solidaire pour mener la
bataille de l'environnement les gens
nous connaissent ça reste important pour
nous mais là on peut aussi en même temps
s'attaquer à la crise du coût de la vie
c'est essentiel parce qu'il y a le temps
des fêtes qui s'en vient et les cartes
de crédit qui vont se remplir il y a des
taux d'intérêt qui vont continuer
d'augmenter du côté de la Banque du
Canada
c'est très sérieux ce qui se passe il y
a Québec solidaire on veut être le parti
de position qui va talonner François
Legault sur cette question là je pense
que le Québécois québécoise ont besoin
d'être ça là d'une opposition forte unie
qui au lieu de chicaner entre elles
Tallone le gouvernement sur les
priorités des gens c'est ce qu'on va
faire et vous avez l'air de voir
l'espèce de fer du côté de l'opposition
officielle puis vous dire mon Dieu on
peut occupé ça cette fois que vous
faites là vous savez au début durant le
dernier mandat l'opposition officielle
avait une
[Musique]
dans les bons moments et être
constructif dans les bons moments mais
monsieur Legault il y a pas besoin de
vous écouter il peut faire passer à peu
près ce qu'il veut puis il peut se
cacher il peut il peut se ranger
derrière
l'argument que une majorité de Québécois
ont élu des députés de son gouvernement
votre voix vous à là-dedans elle est où
en fait la majorité des Québécois n'ont
pas voté pour des députés de la
coalition à venir
québecues
mais c'est pas c'est pas un détail c'est
pas un détail monsieur Lego n'a pas eu
50% plus un des voix il y a une majorité
de Québécois québécoises qui n'ont pas
voté pour son parti ça ça veut dire quoi
ça veut pas dire que monsieur Legault
est pas légitime de gouverner mais ça
veut dire que nous comme opposition on a
un rôle à jouer c'est le rôle d'être la
voix des gens qui ont pas voté pour ce
gouvernement là et forcer monsieur
Legault en faire plus en environnement
en faire plus sur le coup de la vie en
faire plus pour nos services publics
c'est le mandat qu'on a reçu à la
dernière élection et on va jouer parlons
l'environnement sur le groupe propose
d'intensifier les littératification des
transports des entreprises qu'on soit
plus de barrages qu'est-ce que ça
prendrait pour vous convaincre que c'est
une bonne façon de faire on n'est pas en
désaccord sur l'objectif qui est celui
de la carbone neutralité en 2050 le
problème c'est qu'il faut commencer
maintenant à réduire rapidement nos gaz
à effet de serre si on veut atteindre
l'objectif
l'idée de boire de nouveau barrage vous
n'êtes pas en fait le problème avec les
barrages de monsieur Legault c'est que
pour le moment ils sont imaginaires on
sait pas il serait sur quelle rivière on
serait pas il serait construit en quelle
année on sait pas il produirait combien
d'énergie c'est essentiellement une idée
lancée en l'air par monsieur Legault en
campagne électorale ce que les
scientifiques nous disent puisque ce qui
est au Québec nous dit c'est qu'à court
terme on n'a pas besoin de nouveau
barrage pour atteindre nos objectifs de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre en
2030 monsieur le groupe parle beaucoup
des objectifs de 2050 et c'est bien on
s'entend là-dessus mais si on veut les
atteindre des objectifs de
pour commencer par livrer la marchandise
pour 2030 et en ce moment le plan de
lutte au changement climatique du
gouvernement du Québec permet
d'atteindre grosso modo la moitié la
moitié des cibles du Québec pour 2030
donc notre première demande pour
Monsieur charrette et monsieur Legault
c'est de présenter un nouveau plan de
lutte au changement climatique qui va au
moins nous permettre d'atteindre les
cibles de 2030 et ça c'est la première
étape pour être capable d'atteindre
celle de 2050 un terminant votre projet
de loi pour rendre le serment ou
souverain facultatif où il déposer quand
dès la première semaine de la session
parlementaire donc dès la semaine
prochaine projet de loi qui va viser
donc à rendre optionnel ça serment là je
pense qu'on est rendu là au Québec
ça m'a fait plaisir